avec nous ce soir guettant morin
président et chef de la direction du
fonds de solidarité ftq monsieur raymond
soir mon charme ce lien vous nous parlez
comme bien d'autres personnes dans la
société de chez vous présentement
dites nous comment lakovic 19 affecte le
fonds ftq
mais comme la plupart de nos employés je
suis à la maison donc dans les faits
pour nous des périodes de perturbations
comme celle là ça nous a pas beaucoup
plus de travail comme l'a été toute
autre période de ralentissement
économique dont on est vraiment vraiment
au travail au lieu de travail au point
de nous apportera bien sûr mais aussi
auprès de nos actionnaires et il ya
beaucoup d'actionnaires qui nous
écoutent vous le comprenez je présume
que vous avez des demandes de
décaissement en ce moment compte tenu de
la volatilité des marchés
est-ce qu arnaud beaucoup tu te fais
écouter c'est normal et on s'attendait à
ce qu'une période comme celle-là piano
d'un pinceau aussi les gens qui sont
avec nous et qui sont à la retraite ma
le juge que c'est un bon moment pour
demander un rachat de leurs actions
de quelle ampleur s'il avait écouté une
année normale à 2 h au fond c'est aux
alentours de venir soit 55 150 millions
d'années par six taureaux de 750
millions en ces temps de dépasser de
quelques centaines de millions de
dollars cette année c'était prévu nous
avons et liquidités pour faire face à
cette situation là et on a d'ailleurs
nous nos services aux épargnants sont
vraiment à l'aise pour donner le
meilleur sur l'obésité constance à nous
et pas
donc vous avez je pense que c'est très
important de souligner toutes les
liquidités pour tous les décaissements
tout le monde qui demande à décaisser
peuvent le faire il n'y a pas de
problème c'est le moindre de mes soucis
monsieur fillion c'est un test qu'on
fait de façon systématique pour
s'assurer que nous avons les liquidités
à la fois pour nos actionnaires
mais aussi pour redéployer du capital
dans l'économie du québec il ya
plusieurs s'épargne ans le dic se sont
plaints du délais d'attentes avant de
pouvoir parler à un représentant au
fonds de solidarité
est-ce que vous avez réajuster ses
services écoutez au tout début dans les
premiers jours nous avions à se re
nettoyer comme la plupart des québécois
un télétravail c'est aussi le cas pour
nous sauver ce téléphonique
donc évidemment au tout début les délais
d'attentes étaient était très long on a
ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'en quelques
jours le dpi tous ces jaloux en
télétravail avec ce que sainté qu'au
niveau technologique bonne musique mais
on a aussi augmenté de 30 % de notre
capacité de l on disait on a des
standards qui sont très élevés nous
entendant barre 90 % de nos appels sont
répondions à moins de 90 secondes
aujourd'hui malheureusement on est à la
ville un rapport hier on était le délai
moyen aux alentours de 18 milliards
c'est parce qu'on veut par contre les
circonstances je vous disais que c'est
il faut s'habituer cette situation là
dans des périodes comme celle-ci les
gens qui peuvent retirer leur argent qui
on est préparé un tableau ce sont les
actionnaires qui peuvent retirer leur
argent sans pénalité les actionnaires à
la retraite qui ont 65 ans et plus qui
ont perdu leur emploi ou dont les
revenus ont chuté qui veulent acheter
une première maison utiliser le rap qui
désirent retourner aux études à temps
plein est ce que vous voulez élargir
cette catégories d'actionnaires qui
pourrait retirer leur argent sans
pénalité c'est une situation que
beaucoup évolué avec le temps il faut
comprendre que c'est aussi crétin de
rachat leur sont aussi revus par le
ministère des finances
il faut pas oublier que évidemment nous
avons un crédit d'impôt l'aimta des
finances veut s'assurer qu'on conduit
certaines règles aussi que 15 du capital
permanent pour pouvoir réinvestir
laisser être maman il y avait du capital
à long terme
donc on a ajusté au fil des temps feu
distincts pardon
nos critères de rachat c'est quelqu'un
par exemple vous vous parliez tantôt de
la question de perte d'emploi de
situations financières qui sont pas les
temps qui courent il faut faut bien
comprendre que évidemment des situations
aussi pour ça qu'on or certains critères
qui sont reliés à la baisse de revenus
et où par exemple aussi là des
situations de recours de créanciers pour
l'année passée j'ai pas les chiffres
pour cette année ça va augmenter cette
année là n'est pas si s'appesantit kamel
19 millions de chercheurs travaille 3500
demande donc oui on a des critères qui
permettent cette constance
malheureusement comme celles qui ont
envie de pouvoir acheter
on voit de nouveaux critères d'ajouter
pendant la crise actuelle non il faut
nouveau culte et avec cela dit il faut
comprendre que le niveau de l'action au
début du mois de juillet sera
probablement plus bas que le niveau de
l'action au début du mois de janvier
je sais pas de projections à ce moment
ainsi toute cette question de prix de
l'action est ce qu'on entend revoir le
prix de l'action est plus un critère sur
lequel on se base et si jamais on devait
réévaluer prix de l'action on émettra un
communiqué de presse
et on se laisse une période de 30 jours
pour pouvoir revoir ou non le prix de
l'action il parle à cette période-là des
gens vont continuer à pouvoir réussir
leur action on donne les prix ont
annoncé au début de l'année
allez vous jouer un rôle particulier
dans la relance de l'économie du québec
absolument nous avons un plan d'action
en trois atteint travail fallait la
portion du plein que j'appelle liquidité
immédiate est ce qu'on a à faire nous
hante opus pas tendance étant un
moratoire on annonce sur le 19 mars donc
déjà plusieurs semaines de ça un
moratoire de six mois sur le versement
de tout capital intérêts sur ces textes
sociaux si liquidité immédiat
deuxièmement est là elle est en cours on
est vraiment dans cette période là
j'appelle ça c'est la paire de fonds de
roulement
on doit s'assurer que nos entreprises
partenaires et les autres aussi de qui
nous font la demande vont avoir les
fonds de roulement les fonds disponibles
pour se rendre à valence est pour
pouvoir se permettre de relancer les
activités
le troisième le troisième la troisième
phase au plan d'action c'est ce que
j'appelle la portion capitalisation
parce que où la de la reprise
probablement que nos entreprises du
québec devront avant d'être un peu plus
qu'au début
donc il faudra balancer vraiment des
bilans des entreprises
et là on est vraiment au coeur de notre
eau en 1982 ont été créés pour
recapitaliser de capitaliser les autobus
qui était très endettée
c'était de même que 1 194 en 2002 en
2009 aida à ce moment ainsi lors de
relance on va être côté rock les
recapitaliser pour pouvoir fournir le
capital nécessaire aux entreprises pour
compléter certains projets d acquisition
va voir un tacle d'opportunités pour les
entreprises
ils sont là pour s'assurer que le niveau
d'endettement trop élevé à venir le
capital se déployer merci beaucoup
monsieur morin prophète entrevue ce soir
c'est monsieur zizian barcelone à vous